Idol, what's the advantage of the idol, it's safe if it's
the same as your fingers. It's not a slap, cafe, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh.
am
aura free jumped
p aaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaa with
hey jump hey I think it's better to decide with rock-paper-scissors in times like this Um,
if that's the case you won't be able to see me with Let's go like this here It's
video red rock-paper-scissors.  Well
then, let's go. That's the
best. Who said there was a elimination game?
5 people play rock-paper-scissors and keep going until they decide on one dentist.
Then you can play rock-paper-scissors three times and at least once.  If you win, I'll appear on both machines.I know how to
calculate probability.I know that
Mitsuba is trying to become the third generation in a row, but she's an amazing hippo.I've never
lost at rock-paper-scissors, so
me na na na
na  It's
true, this is the last time.
Hey, hey, I don't know what kind of cheating you're doing, but if that's what you want, then I can
give you a break. Hey, it's five colors. Even Mao didn't mention it.
Luck is also a function of ability.  I'm talking about my magical abilities,
right? Well, Mika, right?
[Music] I
haven't lost at rock, paper, scissors since I was a kid. I'm
going to the office. Yeah,
yeah,
jadeite
me. It's a
burden right now. I gave it my all.  But it's
okay
par
true go dai
[Music]
Oh sorry Rock,
paper, scissors, look that way, Heubach pa
This is Mishima, look that
way. After that okay thing, it's
true now.  Oh
well, if you reduce it all day long, you can't lose this game of loading all day No matter
what you do, glaz I've got shoes Joy,
thank you,
go to the brain Kagura turn I've never heard of people going first even though it's rock, paper, scissors J The
first move is guaranteed.  That's why I don't care, Ippei-chan. If you had felt like
it before, I'd have let you go here too.
Yeah, I
would have given you
plenty of time to explore. Me, I wonder if there's enough space for me.
Rear Ah,
what do you mean?  I'm sure Uncle Hito-san said "Gah" at first.If my
child doesn't finish eating this, it's a black curse.I
don't understand why you say that, but I also have a mother like that
.  [Music]
Aaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaatoto, there
is no canoe to me rather than the 4th day in between which
I don't know what to do.
Which of the 5 works will come first?
Well, no, I don't think that's going to happen. The village says, 'Well, it's rock, paper, scissors, rock, paper,
scissors.'
Soke, then the next two-dimensional pop!
Aiko Leisure
Manners that came with us, there's going to be a third round.
[Music] That's not true.
[Applause] There
was one doctor in Abu Dhabi, but I was able to make a final decision anyway. I
decided to play rock, paper, scissors.  What do you think about
me
That's Loco Food's a It's
okay, I'm Paula.
What is this? Aso and water lilies are still giving out chopsticks. I don't like it, so I'm
chasing that kind of guy. Ah,
choppy.
me
can
famous words won. Amazing.
How did they do it?  I'm confident that I can beat anyone at rock-paper-scissors.